it means a lot you know he this is
started like almost like uh
like a joke at first you know like he
was he was like i think a nike ad and he
was sending
like challenge to players to isaiah
thomas the mother rose and all that and
i was like
yeah let me just shoot my shot you know
kind of like
was my challenge and he was like mvp but
that
at first i was like joking i think that
he's gonna respond to me
but when he did he made me believe
like i'm like kobe bryant thinks i can i
can do this i can play in the higher
level and
lead my team and win the mvp you know
and
and i had to do it you know i had to
work hard
you know and not only necessarily let
him down
i had to work hard because people
believe that i can do it
you know and that's that's the thing i'm
a people pleaser
you know i don't like letting people
down i like letting like
when i resign with the city of milwaukee
that's the main reason i resigned
because i didn't want to let the people
down
and think that you know i don't work
extremely hard for them which i do
you know but be able to accomplish those
things in uh
this period of of time is it it's crazy
it's it's unreal it's freaking unreal i
can't
i can't believe it